all right now just to finish either the
bells about to go but this will not take
long
circles easy enough okay this is a
circle set to origin radius R okay
just where it gets a little bit tricky
is when you involve semi circles because
you can confuse it with each other
okay so semi circles involved just what
half of this okay don't go so for
instance if I say and I'm going to start
with wire if I say let's make Y the
subject okay so make Y the subject I'm
going to take the square root of both
sides so in this case you get this now
in this case this is still the entire
circle I've got the plus or minus okay
so where this gets tricky is when you
only have the plus or the minus that'll
only give you the top half or the bottom
half that's easy to work out which ones
which plus is the top because that's the
direction Y is got me and minus is the
bottom right so here's the way I've
always written out for myself right if
I'm going up it looks like this okay so
I've got my y-axis going up and down
here right so if this is y equals the
positive one and this is y equals the
negative one okay this is the y-axis
that's why it's the y equals is okay
doesn't take that much to extend what
happens when I go the other way I'm not
going to make Y the subject I'm going to
make X the subject right so for the
positive side I'm going to get the
positive square root R squared minus y
squared right and to go the other way
I'm still going to get Y X Ronna but
it's negative okay so what I would just
remember is okay think about what is the
subject right that'll tell you am i up
down because I'm looking at wise or my
left right because I'm looking at exit
and then just pay careful attention to
the sign plus is going to go positive
positive or minus is going to go
negative negative make sense